okay i guess people want me to play
chess
um i'll play i'll play a three minute
game
let's play a three minute game one three
minute game and then then maybe i'll go
back to browsing massage shares
because 89 people still want that oh the
finnish
solute saddle chair wait let me
let me type this before i forget it is
there there's no
i was expecting like a really cool
massage chair
but there's no uh there's no backrest
but i feel like i've seen that one
before where you can just sit in
different positions
let's play this move
i was preparing this other day for
andrew ting
um i think a3 is the move
there's some idea like takes takes takes
bishop d3 and then e4
uh i'll play e4 right away
might even include queen e2
i might be threatening i will say i
might be threatening e5
knight t7 and greek gift and do i do it
it's probably really dubious
but also really fun
so if knight g4 my g4 is easy because
i'm in the knight
knight d7 most expected
i should really calculate bishop takes
takes here
i think king ji it's losing to queen h5
which means queen king g6 queen d3 f5
queen g3
there's f4 queen g4
oh my knight but okay king takes here i
have queen h7
oh it's so interesting
i forgot my knight's not defended
because usually there's a bishop on c1
but my bishop somehow disappeared
i have to play queen h7 here because i
can't allow the king to run back
and there's some idea in 94 but there's
always a pawn here
okay so i'm attacking this i'm
threatening probably some sort of
some sort of thing
the king could very easily enter my my
crib
i have no idea what's going on here also
looper thanks for subbing
so i'm down two minor pieces but most of
these pieces aren't really doing too
much
so the critical line is takes takes or
probably
guess either and i could take say takes
takes
knight g6 h4
hmm i also have f4 here
wait h4 king h5 this is almost mating
okay
so king f5 i mean it's great because the
king can't access these squares
but it's not so great because i'm down
two pieces
so i have g4 and g4 might allow the rook
to get involved
this is such a funny position so if
takes i can play queen f6
threatening this and then king f3 queen
g3 would be
mates
there's queen e7 queen e7 is annoying
i have this move too wow there's so many
moves
trying to figure out what to do here
there's also just maybe i'll just
queenside castle
because black wants to play queen d4
yeah and then i keep all the tension
so i'm threading this there's probably
this rook g1 rook g5
this is way more fun to play as white
it's a reasonable move
let's get the rook involved
so rook g5 coming rook g5 king f4 this
is
um it's a mating idea okay now d5 is
hanging
let's take on d5
it's going to come down to time
i could have taken on g6 oh no not yet
but almost let's play f4 because it
looks fun
i'm still down two pieces
okay now i just want to promote
uh you can take that oh let's keep oh
let's do this
no that's a mouse slip
dirty flag incoming
let's go oh what a weird game
so i mouse slipped oh that was
unfortunate
i mouse slipped uh rogue of three i
meant to take on f4
and then the king would have had to take
and i was gonna win the queen
well that was fun play game
i played fast banana oh fast banana was
actually kind of fast
but not fast enough black has made in
one in the final position
three different ways
what a dirty finish the whole game was
just nasty
i don't know also thanks for that
anton i don't know if the greek gif was
good
i assume black's probably just better
here
that was a really fun game though that
might be youtube worthy
people watching in the future on youtube
i hope you enjoyed that be sure to
follow on twitch
if you want to see games like this in
real time
oh check stockfish wait is the game oh
i forgot about the the hikaru magnus
match
but this game was more interesting
yeah black's just up six pawns
stockfish knows best oh
it's changing its mind oh it's really
changing its mind
you see that it went from -6 to just a
draw
so there's only two moves that don't
lose
wow
what did black play oh so now it's
starfish is just terribly confused
i made a nine i'd forced me to nine
thanks for subbing loneu men where's my
maiden nine
oh it's like castled it's still winning
for lights
so force mate was this
what if king oh king f5 i have rook g5
oh and if this i have this
i should have seen that
oh that's funny yeah so the threat of
queen f3 is pretty hard to stop
let's say knight c e5 or gage1 king g2
wow and then
wow look at this if king h1
i c i could queenside castle or i could
delayed bon cloud amro's in what odom
rose and
ah yeah mother though
but it's a good kind of duh because
after this it's meat
and delayed bon cloud for the win oh i'm
so
i'm so disappointed i didn't play that
yeah castling is also kind of funny
okay um i'll probably include that
also in the youtube video